this one by terrell xavier five dollars
thank you terrell
men want a career to get girls the girls
are a prize for his success what is the
prize for women and who's going to care
for
you when you're alive when you're 60
okay so let me let me say that men want
a career so they can have success
women want what
uh
uh
the girls are the prize for his success
the girls are the prize for his success
okay and what is the prize for women
what is the prize for a woman go ahead
pro what is the prize for a woman
for a woman's success what are you
saying for success or in a relationship
for success like okay and success so
okay let me rewind man wants success and
the grand prize is a hot woman
women want success
what is the prize
for that success i'm not talking success
like
career-wise yeah um a lot of money and
lonely
usually
usually an empty apartment but a lot of
money to spend
and that's not doesn't sit well with you
i mean i think people are free to choose
what they want to choose if that's what
you want to do go do it like but i i
think a lot of women
do that and they chase the bag and they
chase the career and then they find
themselves alone at 50 60
and
that's not fun and i think and i think a
lot of older women lie to younger women
about this and that's what rubs me the
wrong way that's why i do what i do
because i just don't believe in lying to
women how do women older women lie to
younger women because they'll say things
like like the happiest sector of women
is like 45 and childless but you could
find 10 studies that disprove that for
the one that they have that didn't have
a proper sample size so you're pushing
this narrative because you don't want to
be alone in your poor choices
and i just that doesn't sit well with me
so they're almost like validating their
poor decisions is what you're saying
yeah and you can see it in the media all
the time like every poor decision a
woman makes like you see it in the media
like for example like women gain weight
right what body positivity that's the
next thing that comes out we just talked
about that jordan peterson rollo yeah
yeah the one big girl was on the cover
of s.i yeah and and i've been overweight
and that you can lose it so why are we
tripping
like why are we tripping and and they do
the same thing with age now too you see
them pushing
like what is it ageism that's the new
word oh yes because the older women are
upset that they're lonely yeah yeah
they're mad that they're not getting the
same sexual offers that they were
getting in their youth and shocking yeah
coco your found success in what you're
doing uh same question to you men find
success and the grand prize is women
what is the grand prize for being a
successful woman freedom and money
because when you have your own career
you obviously make money if you're
successful
money equals freedom so you can do
whatever you want but
to pearl's point let's say you're that
45 year old woman successful millionaire
amazing house you know couple cats
running around shout out to the cat
owners out there but would that be
fulfilling if you never got married and
had didn't have kids i don't think that
you can't be
successful
and have a husband or a boyfriend or
whatever i don't think it's either or
you can do both is what you're saying
yeah because i see it right now like me
and my boyfriend we both work literally
24 7. like we work weekends we like we
work all the time but we both work from
home
okay we both go on meetings go to shoots
and whatever whatever he goes do for his
work but we're still there and we're
still enjoying each other and i what i
love that's why i said that what we
appreciate with each other we're both
very ambitious and we talk about work a
lot and we work on projects together so
it's not that he is doing his own thing
and i'm doing my own thing and we don't
even know what's going on in our work
life do you think do you think he
respects you more because you've got a
lot going on yes he said that he he
would never be with a girl who doesn't
who's not driven got it so respect to
him and and have you ever been with a
guy who found you a little much like too
work oriented like you're a little
intimidating have you been with a guy
like that ever i wouldn't say that i was
ever like intimidating
at least nobody told me that
but i know that a lot of guys don't like
when a girl is very vocal about her
opinion and i'm very vocal about my
opinion so when it comes to being
submissive
i couldn't do that because that's just
not my personality but that's not my
personality and that's why i left the
comfort of my own home that's why i'm
trying to do my own thing go ahead allen
so i have a question because you want to
have this very successful career you i
think earlier in the hallway you said
you wanted to be a billionaire yes and
then you're saying that you're pretty
much in an equal partnership so my
question is is your money going to be
both of yours money or is it just going
to be your money like how are the how
are the finances going to break down in
that
when because earlier i heard you say
that
you wanted all of your bills paid but
then you're talking about having a car
when did i say that i want my bills paid
it was it was much earlier in the
conversation i would have to go back and
rewatch it did i need my bills paid oh
you said you didn't split it 50 50. no i
meant for dinners oh if you're talking
about equal housework
yes so that was my confusion i was like
is your money going to be both of y'alls
no no no no
well let's let's talk about that the
money in a relationship
what should you split what should the
man take care of what should the woman
take care of
let's talk about the money like how does
it work in your marriage well he pays
majority of most of the bills i have a
very small income that i bring in it's
supplemental income but that's mostly
because i can be fulfilled in that i
think if i wanted to make candles and
make no money i think he'd be fine with
that but that's kind of how the
breakdown is and he takes a lot of pride
in doing that he's very happy to protect
and provision and i think a lot of men
don't get to have that opportunity where
they could have that intimate of a
relationship with their wife female
partner
and how does that money work in your
marriage because you said your boyfriend
is pretty successful
uh did i say marriage sorry dear
relationship
what girl
uh how does it work you guys split rent
you guys split food bills utility bills
does he always pay for dinner like she's
being very open and honest saying look
he makes all the money i'm here to
support him you've been open and honest
saying hey we both make money so how do
the bills break down
uh well we kind of try to see
where we're very open with our finances
so like he knows how much i make i know
how much he makes and then we decide
together
what we're gonna spend on what like he
pays the rent so maybe i'm gonna pay for
the car or something so like we so but
he pays the rent yeah
period he pays the rent yeah well the
rent is the biggest expense that someone
will have not necessarily what do you
mean of course it's the biggest expense
no like groceries and the car gets
successful oh groceries are a third one
no i'm i'm not i'm not i'm not a lot of
orgasms
but the reality is rent or housing is
the biggest expense yeah no he pays the
rent okay but
being the man in the relationship paying
the rent you're living technically under
his roof
does that qualify him to have a little
more say in the relationship or no no i
wouldn't say that because i don't
quantify certain things so like if he
pays the rent but maybe i'm gonna
i don't maybe i'm actually physically
gonna go buy the groceries so i'm gonna
put my time and my effort and my energy
into doing something and he's going to
do something else do you do all like the
cooking and cleaning no we we
he's a virgo so he's like
like because he's you know paying the
rent that's really nice does he like
what does he get in return what does he
get in return
he gets a lot in return okay like what
like like i'm going to keep that i don't
know not answered oh okay what did you
mean by that yeah i'm sorry
if a dude was paying my rat like i'd
make sure that every like i would do the
cooking cleaning i would do everything
in the house you're saying if a guy's
paying your rent you're doing everything
yeah free rent what around the youtube
channel though what around the youtube
channel though what do you mean your
youtube channel you really enjoy that
right so i think you would find a way to
fit in your schedule prioritizing your
relationship and while also not
essentially sacrificing all of your
channels yeah i wouldn't i wouldn't just
like do nothing i think you can cook and
clean and still do other things
but i think you guys are miss
hearing what i'm trying to say like if
he pays the rent
okay but let let me give you a whatever
let's say the rent is 5k it's not 5k but
let's say it's 5k
maybe i'm gonna spend 2-3k for something
else so it's not like
tit-for-tat so like he pays rent but
maybe i'm going to spend the same amount
of money for something else so it's more
like 50 50 it's not 50 50 because that's
just not how i was brought up and that's
not how i was raised okay what would you
say it's like 80 20
maybe 70 30. 70 30. okay
is that a fair split
i mean it sounds what what i believe
most women would expect is the 70 30.
they might not say it and i think that
that 70 30 is the new 50 50 because
we're going to downplay the man's money
versus the woman's money if that makes
sense i think this is essentially a
modern relationship and i don't prefer
modern relationships and i think they
have you know their own issues because i
don't think there's that sweet intimacy
that is between a feminine woman and a
masculine man where you just have these
understanding of your roles within the
home but some people want to gender bend
and they want to do their relationships
how they want to do it i know that i if
i had to grow up in that kind of
situation where i didn't see either one
of my parents i don't think i'd be happy
with that
and i want to just say i was in a
relationship before
where i was he was taking care of
everything and i was just like
i still had my thing going on whatever
but like he was in control and i felt
that i i that was just not for me
because i felt very
um like i don't want to hear an argument
like get out of my house like that's not
something i would ever want to hear
so i would not put myself in that
situation because this just doesn't work
for me do you think it depends on the
guy for sure so like maybe that was just
the wrong guy yeah that's yeah maybe
yeah definitely okay